and the president would change you had
bush you had clinton you had bush you
had obama
and the foreign policy wouldn't change
they would there was a joke in 2008 they
said
they told me if i voted for john mccain
we'd get another war in the middle east
and that was true i voted for john
mccain we got another war in the middle
east
obama's foreign policy was basically
indistinguishable
from mccain's foreign policy maybe obama
gave a little more money to iran but in
terms of the constant wars the
never-ending wars
that was the same policy you didn't you
didn't see that really change at all
the policy of bombing saddam hussein
every so often that had been going on
for a very long for a very long time so
that battle is going to come up and the
media haven't learned a thing here
this msnbc host i guess he thought his
microphone was off i guess he thought
the camera
was off but he was asked what he knows
and i thought he gave a very precise
answer
nbc's ken delanian has some new
reporting on something that we talked
about at the top of the hour
how the trump administration is handling
the transition with the incoming biden
team or
not handling it we should say to a
certain extent this time
it involves our intelligence community
uh ken what have you learned sir
okay uh i think we lost think we lost
kent for a second we'll try to get him
back there
now they thought this was a mistake now
they thought this was a mistake that
it was accidental i don't think so i
think that was a very precise answer
what have you learned
not very much i can't use the words
because i'll i'll have to be bleeped out
myself
so that's pretty pretty fair that should
be the headline what is the media
learned
blank blank absolutely blank but then
they cut back to him
they cut back to the guy and and he
makes his point and you hear on the
premise that the biden
president-elect biden is transitioning
in
the election hasn't been called but he's
transitioning how is this going to work
for the intelligence community hey craig
first i want to sincerely apologize to
viewers who may have heard some
uh me use profanity at the top of the at
the last hit but what we're learning
today
is the potential impact of the
resistance of the trump administration
to acknowledge the biden win in the
intelligence arena specifically
the intelligence community why do i care
what the intelligence community thinks
about a duly elected president
or in the case here a not duly elected
president someone who we don't know who
the president is going to be
why do i care what the intelligence
community thinks i like the intelligence
community when they do their job well
that's good i guess it helps our
national security
i despise the intelligence community
when they decide that they are going to
take
our republic into their own hands and
try to undermine or overturn an election
as they did in 2015 and as they did in
2016.
this is what would be one of the
greatest losses
if president trump ultimately does not
prevail in this election
if joe biden is named president one of
the great losses
is that the deep state blob will
solidify will reform
and president trump has done a great job
of exposing these guys had hillary
clinton won in 2016
we would have had no idea no idea
that the deep state under the obama
administration
spied on the trump campaigns used the
weapons of the state to spy on their
political opponents
we would have had no idea that they
cooked up phony intelligence
with the hillary campaign and the dnc to
try to frame president trump which led
to a motor investigation
for however many millions of dollars in
two and a half years which led to
a fraudulent impeachment which led to so
much because of these particular leaks
chuck schumer admitted this early on
when trump said i'm going to clean up
the deep state particularly the
intelligence community
chuck schumer said you should never go
against the intelligence community
they can kill you nine ways from sunday
they can get you
so many different ways they got dirt on
everybody don't go up
against them that is what he said and i
think it was actually probably good
advice to president trump
trump fortunately though had some
courage and stood against it
what do i i don't care that the
intelligence community wants
joe biden installed president before the
legal process plays out does nothing to
me i hope you enjoyed that short segment
from the michael knowles show be sure to
check out the full
episode linked in the description or
download the podcast
wherever you listen to podcasts
[Music]
you